good morning everyone I think it's time
to get started my name is Felina hermans
I'm a full professor of Computer Science
Education at free University in
Amsterdam and I'm here today to talk
about a programming language for
children that I made called The Heavy
programming language and just to give
you like the Highlight in one slide
heady is gradual Hedy is multilingual
and hideous build for teaching and you
might not know what any of those things
mean yet but this is the thing we will
call for in the talk so you just have an
idea of the three things that make heady
unique if people ask you after the talk
like oh what is Eddie all about if you
don't remember anything because you're
like jet lag like me you can just say
Eddie's gradual and multilingual and
built for teaching and then it's like
you actually paid attention
so before we go into details I want to
give you like the backstory of how I
developed Teddy because heady like I
think any programming language ever was
built to scratch my own age but it
wasn't the language I needed myself it
was a language I needed for teaching
because about 10 years ago I became a
teacher initially in a Saturday
programming Club outside of school but
later I actually became and still am a
teacher in high school and in my country
High School is between 12 and 18. so
every week I'm teaching kids right so
the children I initially started with
were a bit younger middle schoolers
between 10 and 14 and they needed a
programming teacher so I was like yeah
sure children I will teach you
programming but some sometimes people
because I'm a professor of Education
people think I have actual knowledge
about education well I do now have some
knowledge about education but when I
started teaching I didn't have any like
experience or knowledge because my
background actually is in programming I
have a PhD in software engineering but
the annoying thing about people with a
PhD are they people with a PhD in the
audience
at least a few yeah so the annoying
people think about us people is because
we have a PhD we think we know
everything so I thought
maybe to teach children they're like
literally small children this will be
easy
it was not easy so what happened when I
started to teach is that subconsciously
I remembered how I learned programming
when I was a kid so this is me behind my
dad's very very big computer
um learning to program but when I was
learning to program there wasn't a
programming lesson there wasn't a
programming teacher because I didn't
know any adults that knew programming so
how did I learn programming well from a
book I had this book basic computer
games and I was allegedly going to show
me how to make games but this was not a
book that said oh this is a for Loop and
this is a variable and this is a while
statement if you would open the book it
would have printed out basic listening
So This is How I Learned programming
right I manually copied all of these
things into the computer and maybe you
hear that English is not my first
language so I had no clue what like for
or if men's or domain words like
velocity like fun fact I didn't know how
to properly pronounce array until I was
in a university I used to say arai
because I got it from a book and English
is weird so I had no clue what any of
this meant but also I had no like
internet or Netflix so what was I gonna
do as a 10 year old I copied it into the
computer because I wanted to have a game
and I think many of us my age like
children of the 80 you learn programming
this way and therefore we think that
compilers are great teachers and we've
been Stockholm syndromes into thinking
that the compiler is our friend
it's like if you're a child and you
don't have any toys right you have a
plastic bag and you draw eyes on it it's
like this is my stuffed animal like this
is how we feel about the compiler it is
my friend it is
so this is how we feel right that the
compiler is our friend this is
definitely what I was thinking when I
started to teach children not explicitly
but it was definitely like the vibe I
was thinking about I just give them
example programs they type them into the
computer and the compiler will tell them
when stuff goes wrong
so just to give you a little bit more
context on the programming Club
initially we started with a programming
language called scratch this is scratch
it is a visual block based language so
you can click blocks together and stuff
happens and it's sort of magic like this
small program makes the cat turn around
and make meow sounds so it's very easy
to get started and to get some
confidence as a kid like oh programming
oh I can I can Master the computer this
is this is good
but then as the children aged a little
bit so they became 11 12 year olds they
said teacher teacher we don't want a toy
language anymore we want to do a textual
language because we see that actual
languages are what the real deal is
that's the thing that makes people money
and specifically the school I work in is
like an inner city school so many kids
want to go into Computing because they
know it's a good job and then this it
doesn't look like a job right this
doesn't look like a career so the kid
said teacher we want to do textual
languages I said no problem children we
do python python is a super friendly and
easy to learn language and we can
totally smoothly transfer from this
friendly UI into python
because scratch kids wanted to go to
python so
this is what we do children we type
prints and then an opening bracket and
then close and then some text and then
another quote and then a closing bracket
and you do that and you know what what
then then text on the screen
okay okay then it sounds like like a lot
of work for text on the screen right but
when I was 10 text on the screen was
like cool like oh we can make Zork wow
this is cool so the kids are not so
super impressed but also it was really
really hard because if they did Tiny
things then already the pilot would like
yell at you for example if you put an
uppercase and P in the print statement
it doesn't work right because then you
get
name error name prints is not defined
and this creates an interesting
cognitive problem because the kid thinks
the computer is smart it can do 314
times 7 in one second so how can it not
fix this
and this isn't even super terrible like
this error message is is doable even for
the children I was teaching Dutch
children this is understandable because
in my language this would be name print
is
so it's still kind of similar so today
so they understood what was happening
but here's another one so here's a
missing closing brackets at the end
right so you could understand that the
child would think the computer can fix
this it's pretty clear what's meant here
but then the computer says syntax error
unexpected eof while parting
so this kid is like teacher teacher what
is parting I'm like don't worry child I
have the Dragon book right here
talk about partying like I want to talk
about parsing but not to a 10 year old
in their first programming lesson right
but then all these Concepts just sort of
jump into your into your classroom
here's another one
teacher I did it perfectly I checked it
five times it's exactly what it says on
your sheet
except it isn't there's a space there
this is like literally an invisible
mistake there's a spike in like robust
no python is like indentation error
unexpected indent teacher wanted an in
that like I don't want to talk about
that now but so
python was not great and then I figured
maybe just maybe compilers are not great
teachers right they're not men to give
feedback necessarily to novices they're
designed to give feedback to
professional adults they aren't a way of
learning unless like me when I was 10
you really really want to and you have
zero other interest right so it's
possible but it's just not very
efficient
and the interesting thing is that the
conversations I was having with the
children in my classroom like they were
having a different conversation than I
was having right so when I showed them
something like this I wanted to show
them repetition look in programming
there's this idea that you can have one
line and you repeat it multiple times
and you can do magic but then the
children weren't focused on the concept
many of them were just thinking oh I
need to put the call on there I need to
put the brackets there I need to put the
spaces there and their brain got so full
that they couldn't really focus on the
concept and this idea is called
cognitive load so the syntax creates so
much cognitive load in the brain of the
students that they can fully focus on
the concepts
so I was intrigued and then I thought
hmm
how do other fields deal with this right
we as a society were able to teach
children language and math how do they
do that without
frying the brains of the children
for example in language we take it
really step by step if you have a
five-year-old and they're learning to
write and I write something like this we
will not say syntax error unexpected
floating a
we will just say Well done buddy like
here's a sticker I'm so proud of you for
doing letters right we don't care it's
it's wrong and then later we say okay
well you can do letters you can group
them in little groups and then they're
words and then you can make tiny
sentences and then we add a rule that
every sentence starts with an uppercase
letter and then we add a rule that every
sentence ends in appearance and and
without really realizing it what we're
doing here is we're adding expressive
power to the language because once you
can end the sentence in the middle of a
line you can make lines that span
multiple sentences right just like
census and a line initially is the same
thing and now it's through Concepts
so rules gradually change that's the
idea of learning and this is also true
in math so math we also don't teach
everything at once we have mental models
that slowly change for example if you
first learn subtraction then in many
cultures we have a different word for it
you might say something like five take
away three and the mental model is there
are five cookies and if I take away
three then there are two cookies if
there are three cookies and I want to
take away five cookies I have three
cookies right so there's zero cookies
left I cannot take more only later we'll
tell students that are something like
below zero I can have two cookies that
to you and the same is also true to for
division eight divided by three
initially my like the right answer is
two remainder two and then later the
right entries two and two thirds and
later the right answer is two six six
six six six six six so we have mental
models that gradually change and this is
fine right children don't forever become
confused because they learn something
that is not entirely correct and that's
later refined so then I thought whoa
these are great ideas
could we do something like that could we
teach a programming language gradually
and that of course is the thing that
Hadi became so Hedy is a gradual
language and let me show you what that
looks like
so this is Hedy and this is heady in
level one because because it's gradual
it has multiple levels in level one you
can simply do prints and then hello
strange loop I will show you that it's
an actual live demo by adding one
exclamation mark and then it just runs
so you don't need any brackets you don't
need any quotes it just immediately
shows you what printing is so you can
fully focus on the content
from the beginning we don't just have
print because we also want to make it
somewhat engaging so something else that
you can do in level one is you can ask
something you can say ask what is your
name and then you can Echo the answer
back so you do hello and then the answer
will be repeated so you do what is your
name my name is Felina and it says hello
Felina
so there is stage right I immediately
show hey children you can do something
like interaction in a computer program
but you don't have to think about it and
just if you want to do this in Python it
would be something like this right so
you have to Define a variable and then
you have to do input
like this oops input
all right this is all the work you have
to do to convey the same concept if you
want to do this in Python
which is like a lot of work
so if you would show something like this
to a kid then it's very likely that
they're not focused on the idea of
inputs and outputs or just like matching
the brackets and the quotes until the
computer stop shouting so with this
simple form we can say hey programming
it's about input and output
and I told you that kids weren't really
so very impressed by text on the screen
so we add a few features to make it just
more fun so one of the things you can do
is you can have code red allow to you so
if I do hello strange loop again
and I enable this read aloud then hello
strange Loot and this is like super
simple this is just a Google speech API
so it isn't very hard to do but kids dig
this especially later on if you have
repetition then you can do like then it
can sing baby shark or Old McDonald's
kids love that so we really want to show
like programming is fun like even if you
go into a textual programming language
call me from something like scratch you
can make things that are pretty engaging
what I also want to show to you is that
our error messages are not terrible I'm
really proud of that so imagine you make
a tiny mistake and you run the code then
it says but it's not a level one command
did you mean print but because our level
language is so small at this level is
relatively easy to guess what's going on
so we have error messages that are quite
actionable and readable as a sentence
in level 1 in addition to the text-based
output initially we only had text but
that was still very limited so we now
also have the turtle also you can run
the turtle also in level one and you can
make little drawings and something that
we added recently that I'm super excited
about this maybe you noticed that this
save button here appeared you can save
this button and it creates a file that
you can load onto devices like an
embroidery machine or a pen filter so
we're doing this with children in the in
the classroom that we allow them to make
a turtle thingy and then they embroid it
onto their t-shirt and that also again
makes it like more tangible and fun and
exciting
so as I said Harry has different levels
so this was all level one and then in
level two we add variables but we do it
again in a very low key way so I can say
name is heady
and then print hello name and this just
runs
this is Magic right to your programmer's
Bridge like
wait one is a string and the other one
is a variable name like but that doesn't
matter at this level we just want to
show children hey a variable you can
save something give it a name and you
can use the name later and of course
this does create some problems because
if you want to do something like my name
his name this doesn't work well I mean
it does run but it replaces name
everywhere so now this is a good way to
talk about quotation marks with children
it's like look this happens if you don't
have them so wouldn't it be nice if you
could tell the computer like what is a
string and what is a variable name and
then that's a problem that we solved
later on so in level four when we add
quotation marks we show this as the
problem and then the quotes are an
answer to a problem rather than
something you just have to do because
the teacher tells you to right
in level 3 just to take you to a few
more levels we have 18 levels so I can
do all of them in level three we add
lists so we add lists
so you can do a list of animals and then
you can select from the lists at random
so again immediately we create some idea
of this is why you would make a list
because then you can select something
randomly rather than something like the
final list and then print list element
one like why am I doing a list if I'm
not using the list and then as I said in
level four we add the quotation marks
but that's the only thing we add so
children can really really focus on
doing the quotes and then not be so
cognitively overloaded by all the other
things we're learning so that's just to
give you an idea of the progression of
the levels and then level 18 is a
functionally a functionally correct
subset of python so we really slowly
move them to Python and they're like
take away the curtains it's like no
you're doing Python and it wasn't so
super painful we hope
so that was the gradual nature so I
promised you like the three unique
features this is the gradual nature
slowly over time or adding syntax and
we're adding Concepts but honey is also
multilingual
and for that again we need to do a
little bit of a backstory so when I
designed honey in the end of 2019 I
designed it just because it would be a
fun Christmas break programming project
and because I thought it would really
add value in my own classroom but of
course after a while this turned into
proper research and I did a study
because I really wanted to figure out
like do kids like Hattie is this a thing
that works so we did a user study with
39 children in 12 online lessons because
it was the pandemic so we put a new
actual classroom observations and we
asked these children what do you see as
the benefits what do you see as the
challenges and what do you see as the
improvements of heady so this is very
much for dissipatory research I really
want to do this together with students
and take their input into account
so some kids really said oh those levels
I like it because it's really a
step-by-step guide it really tells me
what I should do when and I was like yes
that's what we're going for
what I also very much like is the
teacher of this class that that with
Hattie all kids learn song programming
they used to do python before and he
says with python some kids learn
something but many kids don't learn
anything because they keep hitting the
syntax wall and they just never get past
it and he says but Harry everything
learns everyone learned something some
kids get to level seven or they get Auto
get all the way to python but at least
everyone is learning so it's like yes
another teacher involved in this study
this was a female teacher that was
giving courses to only girls and she
said did you make Eddie for girls and I
was like not specifically but she said
it's so good for girls because the
Little Steps really give confidence
sadly we know that girls often come into
programming classes with lower
confidence in their programming
abilities because well Society tells
them that they will not be good at it
right so if you're already unsure about
your abilities and your first error is
unexpected syntax AOL then that's going
to reflect way harder on your
self-confidence if it's already low so
we didn't build it specifically for that
but I do see how that would work
so we also asked children how can we
make Heidi better and one of the things
that children said is yeah we would like
some better error messages so I was like
well our error message already are quite
good for example this one here a child
is typing a coma in a place where it
isn't allowed and then this clearly says
there is a mistake on line one position
12. why isn't this clear to you child
can you read this error message to you
so the child's like sure teacher I will
read the error message mistaken online
one in position 12. you typed but that
is not allowed
I don't know what typing is not allowed
I'm typing all the time
they didn't see the comma
it makes so much sense if you think
about it right because what do we teach
children Akuma is a little pause if you
see a comma I do not skip ahead stop
right so the child is exactly doing what
we told them and then now it doesn't
work so we change this actually because
this should be a coma and this is a
newer version of the UI we now also have
syntax highlighting as you can see and
now I just said you typed a coma but
that is not allowed which makes so much
more sense and this is really like the
little things you will only get from
observing children being frustrated then
you know you can really get it to a
higher level but what these children
also said is yeah we would like to have
Dutch keywords so the UI initially was
always localized so the explanation and
the error messages were already in Dutch
but the children said why can't we
program in touch
and I was like like really like that
children are supposed to be really good
at English and we teach you from like
age six in schools really but of course
I was reluctant because I was like
that's gonna be a lot of work I don't
want to do that it's like really and
actually I was like yeah yeah why not
why wouldn't we be able to program in
Dutch
it's like yeah yeah
because it's a lot of work that's why
anyway
we did build the localization so this is
the UI as you see it in English but here
we have a language switcher and we now
support 31 different languages so let me
show you what it looks like thank you
what it looks like in my language
so this is Dutch
um you see that everything is now
changed into Dutch but the commands are
still in English so print and ask and
Echo but I have a language switcher here
and I can say well I would like to see
everything in Dutch and then Prince and
Echo is also in my language the same but
ask has now been turned into frag and
you could if you make an account which
is free then you can also set your
profile language and you don't get the
switcher and it's just always there in
your language so this is what Dutch
looks like you will get Dutch error
messages everything is in touch so at
this point I'm like really happy with
myself right look we have Dutch and then
we added a French and Spanish and German
and Italian I was super happy but then I
have a friend and he's from Palestine
and he was like so impressive Latin
languages from left to right wow well
gone hair months so cool
so I was like yes but it won't be a lot
of work
but yeah I know I have no life and it
was a pandemic so we did it we also are
available in right to left languages
like Arabic and then as you can see
everything switches
with the switcher once everything
changes to Arabic so everything's right
to left all the commands are Arabic all
the error messages are Arabic syntax
highlighting works just to show you if I
make a mistake here then I will get an
error message that's also in Arabic ah
[ __ ] in my browser cached the Dutch from
that message but if you would run at a
bunch of times then that would also be
Arabic so there was yeah it was a lot of
work but it's it's really really so
valuable to see children use programming
in their own language and what's
interesting is that initially I very
much thought this was like a social
justice issue like like they deserve
programming in their language and this
is also true but what I also found
observing children use this is it's also
so very much an ergonomics issue because
if you have your keyboard set to Arabic
you type it you first have to set it to
English to type an English keyword then
you have to set it again to Arabic to
type an Arabic string and that switching
is just so annoying and it makes also
the classroom conversation really hard
because a teacher will say it's print
it's p r i n t but children don't know
these letters they don't know where they
are on the keyboard so it's so much also
a practical issue in addition of course
also people are deserving of programming
in their own language so yeah we build
that view
so we did gradual and we did
multilingual so there's one more thing I
want to talk about and that is that Hedy
is a language that is built to teach
with mainly because I build it for
myself in my role of teacher
when we ask children why Hattie works
the children said well the levels are
step-by-step guide but what we also
realized is that this also works for
teachers so well right because the
teacher can just boot heady and then it
will tell the children in his or her
classroom what to do so it's really
really clear how to use it whereas if
you compare that to scratch right if you
look at scratch I have tried many times
to teach scratch programming to
Elementary or High School teachers and
you can get them to understand the
basics right it's not that hard but then
okay I understand programming I
understand the basics now what do I do
in the classroom
scratch doesn't have really a built-in
lesson plan by Design that's that's not
because there are no builds for teaching
they're built for learning which really
is not the same thing so then a teacher
is like well I have to look at all these
different lesson plans there's so many
on the internet but they're all super
different some might start with a
program some might start with different
basic looks you don't know if it's good
you don't know where it goes you don't
know if it's made for your age group so
this is really hard and then even if you
settle on a lesson plan this again is
ergonomics so you selected a lesson plan
you print it out on a sheet of paper or
you put it in a second tab but now the
child has to move their attention from
the lesson to the programming field
right they have to look at the lesson
they look at the programming Fields oh
what do I have to do again look back at
the lesson oh yeah this is the blocks I
need to use look back on the programming
interface and so many energy is lost
because it's really hard to understand
what you have to do if you don't really
understand what's there so this is also
something that has a lot of cognitive
loads because you have to keep switching
between the UI of the programming and
the lesson plan
so what we have built into heady let me
show you another demo what we've built
into heady is the idea of Adventures so
I didn't really show that yeah but if
you scroll up in the UI you have all of
these things that you can do in any
level so you can say how in level one
well we can do print and ask and Echo
what can we do well for example we can
create a parrot and this parrots will
repeat what your name is twice right and
we still have to read aloud so it says I
am heady to parents him hat is a parrot
what's your name
let's do Harry Harry Harry Harry so
[Music]
and that this is for children but also
for the teacher you can just say wow you
just do any of these things you can
explore everything that's there we have
like a restaurant where you can order
something oh you want to have a red wine
I want to have a red wine so it repeats
that it gives an idea of in every level
what is there so it's really this out of
the book solution that tells teachers
this is what's there in level one and
this is what you can build
there's one more challenge I want to
talk to you about and that's the
challenge of managing many different
students in your classroom so I'm
currently teaching I have 28 12 year
olds in my classroom
so just to give you a sense of what that
looks like if this is the lesson plan
there will be maybe one student that's
like yes I've been a teacher Lucas right
there I'm like yeah you're my favorite
student right but then another one
another one is like this like yes I did
one bull I need help because I did one
thing and I need like confirmation that
I'm on the right track and like yeah
sure I will like explain it to you in a
slower pace and then there's another
student and this is like as a teacher my
nightmare because this is me when I was
a kid teacher I ignored everything you
said and I built this
Luke isn't that great but now I want the
Palm to be blue instead of green can you
help me get there
so more of you so managing like the
level in your classroom is really really
hard and I think this is really a place
where just like the philosophy of Hedy
is different from the philosophy of
scratch right inscribes it is made that
everyone can build anything and then as
a teacher you just have to deal with
this right and I I totally understand
that but we are really trying to make
teachers lives easier maybe at the
detriment of these type of students not
being able to immediately reach their
potential so what we allow teachers to
do is to entirely customize the UI that
Harry has so I'm just going to show you
what it looks like as a teacher
so this is me as a teacher so I have
created a class so I can go back to the
classes so you can see the teacher page
so I see I have different classes this
is my actual class in my actual school
and this is my demo class so I see
there's one user in My Demo class called
Felina this is me in another browser and
what I can do is I can customize the
class entirely so that I can set how it
looks like for my class so now you see
all the levels are open and all the
adventures are open but I can say well I
don't want to have any of these levels
because it's just going to be
overwhelming I don't want this level and
I just want to have the parrots and the
turtle and nothing else
so this is what it looks this is Felina
logged in right this is what it looks
for me initially everything is there but
now if I save this adventure I can say
this is the customization and it has now
been saved now if I go to Felina in this
browser
maybe when the page loads then it will
yes you can see that it is now simpler
because some of the advantage Adventures
have been removed we also have at the
end puzzles and quizzes that you can use
to show to see what your students are
doing you can also enable and disable
them so you're entirely empowered as a
teacher to organize your classroom in a
way that you want to giving some X some
students access to certain levels and
blocking of access to other levels so
that the cohort like stays together a
little bit so that you don't have to
manage your energy between one line of
code and 1000 lines of code because
that's just really hard if you have
multiple students in your classroom
so that was heady if you realize if you
wondered why is Harry Hedy is because
he's named after Hedy Lamarr she was a
famous movie actress but also an
inventor and she invented an algorithm
called frequency hoping that's also in
your Wi-Fi router that whenever a level
is full then it hops to a new level
right see why she is an amazing namesake
um so before we go to q a I just want to
like call out because I need all of your
help I didn't come here to make friends
I came here to find contributors so
we love your help for example like the
three things that we're building are
also three ways in which it can help us
so you can imagine that a gradual and
multilingual Barger is very hard to
build like barter Frameworks were made
for exactly one language certainly not
for 18 levels times 31 natural languages
so we're really doing so many of the
work there we have a paper coming out in
the Journal of computer languages about
an extension to EB and f that we made
that allows us to better Define the
changing grammars over time and one of
the authors of this paper is actually
one of our open source contributors on
GitHub so really really proud of that of
like merging the open source Community
with the academic community so this is
the paper it's already online so if you
want to read it you can find it through
our website
if you are not a programmer or you don't
feel like contributing to another open
source project with code you can also
help us add translations as I said we
have 31 languages but not all of them
are equally complete sometimes people
start a language and then after a while
they just stop translating we just we're
still happy with contributions so you
see that some of our languages are more
developed than other languages so if you
know any of these languages that are in
red you can help us extend but if you
know any languages that are not yes on
our list we will be super grateful if
you would help us with the translation
you don't even need to go on GitHub for
that we have a web UI where I can just
translate called Web lathe so you can
just translate in a browser and it
generates a pull request for you
so finally you can help us to find
teachers right very often if I give a
talk like that people come up to me and
they're like oh Eddie sounds fantastic I
will totally do it with my children and
I'm like yeah your children are not my
problem right they have at least one
parent that is a programmer maybe two
right so I'm sure your children will be
fine even if you do python with them or
scratcher even if you do assembly
because you will be sitting next to them
helping them out right so they'll be
fine but who really needs this are
children in situations where there's
maybe not a computer in the house where
they're not a parent to help them and if
you find one teacher then that's maybe
like 30 students over five years that's
really going to scale and that's gonna
Reach people that normally don't come in
contact the programming so something you
can do is like help teachers find heady
we have an online lesson plan we explain
everything with little videos like this
is how you do and we have an online
community as well for teachers so we
really really want to rope in teachers
because we believe that this is
something that can help them teach so if
you want to join us you can go to
heady.org join and all the information
about how to join the Discord and the
GitHub are right there
with that I think it is time for Q a but
before we start I I follow the two holy
rules of q a those are the first
sentence is a question and Rule 2 there
is no second sentence
[Applause]
yes do we have a mic for questions
do you just want me to repeat the
question go ahead
great question so we aim for about two
hours per level so that means that you
have about
18 times too like so it's almost 40
hours and that's if you do one hour
every week in the classroom that's one
academic year so that's more or less
what we think it would take you but of
course this depends on the age and the
program knowledge and the expertise of
the teachers but more or less one
academic year would be enough to go from
the basics to Python and then you can do
python afterwards
hahaha
those are not following exactly my rules
so I'll start with the first one yeah so
the lesson plan
I was already teaching python before so
most of it was we took what we were
already doing in Python and then
transforming that into heading but
there's very much tension in some of the
levels like in level one I also want to
show the turtle because I want to
attract children that aren't maybe not
so interested in the text but that means
we have five commands which is maybe a
bit too much so it is this like a little
bit of tension between want to make it
exciting and want to make it
um
yeah doable
um we have repetition in level seven and
we already have variables in level two
so level seven
yes
if you're starting in
which by the time you get through level
18 are you
are you in Python in English or how does
that work yeah that's a great question
so in level 18 you can still do python
in your own natural language but so then
if you want to make the transition this
is going to be a hard transition
where it's really hard to do so like I
am trying to be hopeful that maybe the
work we're doing is also impacting other
programming communities and that maybe
there will be something like python in
Arabic or other programming language
because it's not so hard right it is
doable
um so hopefully this will create a
generation also of students that say
well now you have to go to python why
isn't python in my language so that's
like I know this is also a way of making
it more my problem but I do think I do
think that's where where we could go as
a community but this is really hard
specifically if you have to go to left
to right and to a different alphabet
yeah
that's hard yeah
yeah some of it so the question is like
is this also does this also work for
adults so we definitely think it worked
for adults this this step-by-step
approach actually works really well so
we're aware of some universities like
our first year students you know are
they adults I don't know
um maybe but so we are aware of some
universities that use it and I just
disable all the adventures like you
don't want to do oh I'm a parrot but you
can put some other lesson plans in there
and if you want to you can just remove
all our adventures put your own
Adventures there it's not like something
we are targeting right now because I
just like children better it's just more
fun but like the way of teaching will
work and the interface like isn't
designed for it perfectly but you can do
it and we've been hearing from more and
more universities specifically in
non-english languages for example in
Pakistan and Indonesia we know the
universities are using it specifically
because of the localization
yes so the question is can I help a
school to get started we definitely have
some of the people in our community that
are also on Discord have done the same
path right there are also programmers
going to a school giving lessons there
of course it depends really on what type
of school in your relationship with the
school how to approach it but we
definitely have had people in our
community I started as someone that
wasn't a teacher helping a school well
they wrote me in so that's a risk but so
we have people with that experience that
can give you some pointers on how to get
started there
uh so we're a pretty active open source
project we close about 154 requests
every month that also includes a lot of
translation so it's not just code
um we have about 10 to 15 people that
are really active like on Discord
basically every day but your level of
involvement it can be really different
so some of the translators they just
come in they translate for one weekend
and then they add the translation and
then we never see them again so that's
definitely something that you can do
some people are they teach weekly and
they chat about what how they told and
what their experiences was on the
Discord like every every time they teach
so it really depends we're also super
happy with like drive-by contributors
it's just like oh I saw a little bug
okay I fix it yes that's also fine but
there's definitely also room for people
to join the community to help us also
spread this to other people
thank you
um do you know how many schools are
currently using heading yeah so a few
hundred schools many of them in the
Netherlands a few also in the US that I
know of
um so yeah a few hundred schools and
sometimes also so you have this
interface where you can create a class
but you don't have to you don't have to
make accounts so sometimes we also see
some sort of Spike without new accounts
and so that maybe just someone is using
it in the classroom without creating the
accounts that's also still a way to use
it so we don't always see what classroom
usage is versus home usage or or other
usage but then a few hundred classes are
in the system so those are definitely
schools oh well you already had a
question so I'm gonna do first timers
first
yeah so the question is like do how do
students feel about differences in the
in the constraints uh so I think this is
a generic thing that isn't just for
heady right if they're doing reading
then it will also be oh I've already
finished my lessons oh you can do an
extra assignment this is something
that's very common already in the
classroom so for a teacher to say oh all
of you are level three oh but you can
already do level seven this is something
yeah whether you like it or not that's
not heavy specific this is classroom
practice because there is such a big
difference especially in elementary
school in the ability and speed and the
the determination like how robust
children are against errors okay
the organization is showing that we
should wrap it up so let's do one more
question and then we have to wrap it up
yes
ah you did the survey of the 39 children
ah you mentioned the benefits and
challenges uh but you didn't really go
into the challenges yeah
yeah because I had to cut time there are
videos where I talk about that specific
thing
um so one of the challenges that
children still see is that they have to
remember the codes even though there's
examples sometimes they forget a certain
words and then there's frustration like
oh I forgot this which still also I tell
them I've been programming for 30 years
I still forget content but this is
something they struggle with and another
thing they specifically struggled with
that is highly specific is that there
are sometimes changes so then they do
level two code in level three and our
partner is sort of robust against that
so if you do code at the wrong level
then we will tell you hey this is level
two code in level three but still
they're like oh why does it work anymore
so that that's those switches which also
we know from language and math education
switching your mental model that is hard
so we can do something with error
messages a little bit but but of course
also this remains just a problem of
learning if people are interested in
joining the community or just showing
support I have some stickers so if you
want to ask me a question then grab a
sticker feel free to do that